fare un viaggio del genere ti apre gli
occhi su tante cose
[Musica]
se all'inizio vedi tutti i problemi che
ci sono perché parli con le persone che
le vivono
poi vedi anche tutte le realtà che
esistono per cercare di risolvere questi
problemi per trovare delle soluzioni che
poi tu devi tutta la meraviglia che
abbiamo visto noi
quello che manca è una coscienza
ambientale radicata nella nostra e nelle
altre popolazioni
quando ci renderemo conto di tutto ciò
sarà il giorno in cui le cose
cambieranno
[Musica]
che avete visto in realtà il primo
minuto del nostro documentario che si
chiama controcorrente ed è stato un
viaggio on the road di 6.000 chilometri
in 30 giorni per affrontare lo stato
dell'acqua dal punto di vista sociale
politico ed economico è più che altro
documenta gli effetti il cambiamento
climatico a in italia perché spesso
quando si parla di emergenza climatica
si pensa che le sue ripercussioni siano
in zone del mondo per noi remote ma non
è affatto così
e parla d'acqua perché l'acqua è
l'elemento imprescindibile per la vita
di ognuno di noi e soprattutto perché
l'elemento che ci permette di
comprendere realmente che cosa sta
accadendo a livello globale quindi
fusione dei ghiacciai innalzamento del
livello del mare fino ad arrivare poi
all'inquinamento delle acque e a sistemi
di depurazione e tubature non a norma
ora al di là del contenuto del
documentario questo documentario è il
primo impatto zero noi abbiamo calcolato
la carbon footprint del documentario sia
le emissioni di co2 prodotte dal momento
in cui io daniele abbiamo iniziato a
scrivere questo progetto fino all'ultimo
export che abbiamo fatto in sala di
montaggio e poi siamo andati fisicamente
letteralmente a compensare queste
missioni piantando un bosco di 200
alberi queste realtà ha fatto sì che non
solo ne compensassero le nostre missioni
ma che venissero sopra compensate di
circa tre volte
questo noi lo abbiamo voluto fare per
mandare un segnale un settore di cui si
parla troppo poco quando si parla di
sostenibilità che appunto l'industria
del cinema e dell'audiovisivo a livello
globale la filiera cinematografica
emette circa il 2 per cento di emissioni
totali
e questo perché i set gli studi
televisivi le sale di montaggio e tutto
ciò che ruota attorno e altamente
impattante a partire da i consumi per
andare poi ai trasporti e finire poi i
materiali che al termine della
produzione non vengono non verranno neri
utilizzati
produzione successiva mesbah al tt
adeguatamente e quindi diventano rifiuti
oggi qui si parla di soluzioni e quello
che noi possiamo fare nel nostro piccolo
e parlare di soluzioni nel settore che
ci coinvolge maggiormente istituire dei
protocolli regolamentati e
standardizzati che impongono alle
società di produzione ea tutta la
filiera cinematografica un impatto zero
a monte quindi in fase di sviluppo e di
produzione e poi una compensazione come
quella che abbiamo fatto noi impostano
perché dalla fase di un progetto più
difficile da rendere impatto zero non
solo porterebbe degli enormi benefici ma
soprattutto avrebbe come conseguenza
diretta l'educazione ambientale del
lavoratore che trovandosi ad attuare
delle buone pratiche sul posto di lavoro
automaticamente riverserà le stesse a
casa nella sua vita privata
la la nostra generazione ma soprattutto
quelle successive alla nostra hanno una
grandissima sensibilità per quanto
riguarda l'emergenza climatica e le
tematiche ambientali ad essa connesse in
realtà quello che servirebbe
l'educazione ambientale ad un'altra
fascia d'età che quella che va dai 40 ai
60 anni
e questo perché innanzitutto banalmente
a livello numerico è quella predominante
e poi perché è la fascia d'età che
occupa praticamente tutti i ruoli di
potere sia della politica e della
pubblica amministrazione che delle
aziende ed è una generazione che ha
figlia del boom economico dell'usa e
getta e soprattutto di un modello
economico che non è più né moralmente né
ambientalmente sostenibile e non
possiamo aspettare di essere noi ad
occupare le poltrone quei ruoli di
potere perché
non c'è più tempo quindi proprio a tal
proposito quello che vi voglio dire io
invece è proprio partire da questa base
dal fatto che esiste una generazione che
nonostante sia quella che meno ha avuto
diciamo ha causato questa crisi
climatica ma anzi è quella che magari ha
fatto proprio più delle altre
una propria competenza acquisito le
chiavi di lettura per agire che è quella
che poi subirà gli effetti maggiori di
questo cambiamento climatico e inoltre
vive quotidianamente sulla propria pelle
anche un'altra critica è quella della
precarietà
nell'italia del post covip il tasso di
disoccupazione giovanile ha raggiunto
delle cifre esorbitanti siamo arrivati a
oltre il 30 per cento con delle punte
che arrivano al 70 per cento in sicilia
e in campania
stiamo parlando di ragazzi che hanno
dedicato la propria vita per anni a
studiare a fare degli sforzi economici
sociali circa due milioni di ragazzi si
sono trasferiti dal sud dal mezzogiorno
verso il nord
negli ultimi 15 anni e che cosa hanno
alla fine anno le competenze ma non
hanno degli sbocchi occupazionali
quindi se queste tematiche le tematiche
relative al cambiamento climatico
debbono essere affrontate devono essere
affrontate subito
e allora che diventino subito un volano
di sviluppo anche economico per questo
paese che andrebbe a generare decine di
migliaia di posti di lavoro perché le
soluzioni ci stanno ma se ne stanno
andando e se ne stanno andando negli
ultimi dieci anni se ne sono andati più
di 182 mila studenti laureati all'estero
in questo modo l'italia che cosa fa va a
regalare agli altri paesi il proprio
investimento sul futuro loro entusiasmo
e le loro competenze e noi se vogliamo
parlare di una transizione ecologica
dobbiamo avere la possibilità agli
strumenti per farlo perché sennò oggi
noi siamo qui a parlare di risoluzioni
ma senza alti mezzi per noi è veramente
difficile e noi nel nostro viaggio
abbiamo incontrato decine di attivisti
professori ricercatori che
quotidianamente cercano e trovano queste
soluzioni nonostante i mezzi non
adeguati che hanno
e dico non adeguati e non è una sorpresa
dato che comunque l'italia fanalino di
coda per investimenti nella ricerca e
nello sviluppo e quindi quando mancano i
mezzi il capitale umano non ci possiamo
sorprendere nel nostro viaggio poi siamo
andati a vedere con i nostri occhi molte
tematiche una soprattutto vi voglio
raccontare quella della scomparsa della
fusione dei ghiacciai nel 2050 il 70 per
cento di questi scomparirà e con esso la
disponibilità di acqua e questa
disponibilità se noi l'abbiamo a sommare
invece al problema della siccità al
problema del della variabilità climatica
che già ogni giorno ogni anno ci fa c
comincia a mostrare su effetti che anno
dopo anno diventerà ancor maggiore
e allora vuol dire che noi dobbiamo
agire subito e dobbiamo agire subito in
che modo cercando di efficientare ed
utilizzare nel modo migliore possibile
ma come abbiamo come si stava dicendo
prima se no abbiamo una rete di una rete
idrica che dalla captazione
all'adduzione alla distribuzione perde
acqua da tutte le parti allora di che
cosa stiamo parlando
ogni 10 litri che dovrebbero arrivare
nel nostro appartamento 4 vengono persi
nel tragitto
e se a questi due dati aggiungiamo il
fatto che noi italiani siamo il primo
paese europeo e il secondo mondiale per
consumo di acqua in bottiglia ripeto
secondo paese mondiale
evidentemente abbiamo qualche problema
evidentemente le concessioni idriche che
permettono alle aziende imbottigliatrici
di acquistare mille litri di acqua un
euro per poi rivenderla al prezzo che
tutti noi sappiamo e proviamo sulla
nostra pelle
ecco allora se la tematica deve essere
quella dello sviluppo di un cambiamento
di una transizione ecologica ecco allora
probabilmente potremmo cominciare ad
analizzare questi tre indicatori e ad
andare a progettare finalmente una vera
manutenzione del nostro sistema idrico e
se l'altra emergenza è quella dei
giovani che hanno le competenze ma non
lavorano allora facciamo questo progetto
però fate partecipare i giovani dalla
fase di progettazione alla fase di
realizzazione
e chiudo sostenendo anche il fatto
ricordando
fatto che il paese l'italia è un paese
che è per il 90 per cento al rischio
idrogeologico
stiamo parlando di una cosa che è
gravissima e se noi la sommiamo a quello
che abbiamo detto prima allora ci
rendiamo conto che quello che bisogna
fare
bisogna farlo oggi bisogna agire ora con
un progetto vero breve medio e lungo
termine
quello che posso dire io a nome della
mia generazione della nostra generazione
è che noi ci siamo siamo pronti quando i
governi il governo la pubblica
amministrazione le aziende vorranno
finalmente è realmente una mano da parte
nostra
ecco sappiano che noi siamo pronti e
forse tutti insieme questa emergenza la
supereremo
grazie